[Music]
the new netflix film robin robin pushes
the envelope of what's possible with
stop-motion animation and follows in the
creative footsteps of classic aardman
films like wallace and gromit shauna the
sheep and chicken run the
symbiosis with technology has massively
helped we're able to do things now with
stop-motion that you know wouldn't have
been possible not so long ago the film's
young directing duo championed new
textures and new visual effect
techniques while staying true to the
artisanal spirit of aardman studios the
robin robin world is all handcrafted
every snowflake in it has been shot in
camera hand animated so we didn't want
any cg in the film let's break down the
timeline and the technique of the new
stop-motion aardman flick
the whole production took about two
years from when we were kind of green
lit to when we finally delivered the
final film probably about a year of that
was uh writing and storyboarding from
the script the film went through the
prep and design phases before any
puppets were built out of needle felt
the characters were crafted on paper and
there's no undo button on the set of a
handmade film like this so dan and mikey
had to get their story straight with a
rigorous pre-production regimen that
took nearly an entire year one thing
that we did right from the beginning was
to make a color script of the whole film
to kind of use color to help tell in the
story you've got to know exactly what
you're doing when you get in the room
and start filming with an animator you
know you've got to know exactly to the
second what you're going to shoot
because of that it means that you
effectively make a rough version of the
film before you go on to set before you
even start shooting that version we call
it an animatic it's made from
storyboards and edited together with
like scratch sound and music and we'd
often do like the voices of the
characters if we hadn't recorded them by
then so you kind of get this rough
impression of what the film is going to
be like i think we had initially sort of
eight eight months to build that
animatic because of the nature of
stop-motion you need to be shooting
scenes all at once so that required
crafting at least five different puppets
of each character in at least three
different scales so that's 75 puppets
including nine robins 11 magpies 20 mice
4 cats 4 squirrels 3 frogs and 3
hedgehogs our job on a day-to-day basis
was so much fun of going into all these
different rooms with like different
parts of the world being rendered at
different stages and pretty much every
set was sort of built specifically for a
particular set of shots the art
department are busy the whole time kind
of crafting the next set that's sort of
the tradition of stop-motion sets is
that they're always able to break apart
and move around partially because you've
got to get animators into the set here's
dan mapping out the path of one of the
characters blocking the action much like
on a live action set the sort of
blocking process was a really important
part of of sort of being able to figure
out exactly what you're going to get at
the end of the shot because with
stop-motion you know it's very hard to
do a retake because it takes
we weren't really allowed on this
project because of the schedule once the
set's in place you then uh have the
process of you have the rigors there's a
huge rigging department that there's a
lot of scaffolding that kind of goes
into moving these puppets around and
then we have the camera department which
was led by our incredible dop dave alex
riddick who is the the dop on the wrong
trousers and there's a huge uh tradition
of making films at admin
and he would then light the set so you
know he would paint with light um so
there's lots and lots of cameras set up
and lots of lighting preparation that
goes in then before the animator is
finally able to step up to the stage and
then we had about an eight month
shooting window so we filmed for eight
months a team of 14 animators each
banked about eight seconds of footage
per week we don't shoot anything
sequentially well one shot in particular
it was a big shot and a big set piece of
the film which is robin's song right at
the beginning of the film where she kind
of dances her way through their rubbish
dump home it was a pretty long shot like
over 20 seconds and also involved the
camera move and a lot of choreography
there was a lot of puppets in it
probably took about a week to set up the
motion control and get the camera
working right after that you'd have like
all the lighting tweaks which took
probably another few days or maybe a
week and then once the animator's ready
they'll come in and
for that particular shot he did a block
which took him about a week that whole
one shot was probably like five weeks
in one unit so you've got to make sure
that that camera move is right and that
it's not going too fast and it's going
to leave them behind so he was in there
every day for two weeks animating this
sequence we just sort of like locked him
in there
came back in two weeks and he'd made
this absolute masterpiece
[Music]
the fundamental basics of stop-motion
have probably
remained the same for a hundred years
which you have something you move it a
little bit take a picture move it a
little bit so there's 12 frames per
second so 12 images every second are
taken as an animator they've got this
great ability to plan things out very
meticulously but also capture like a
real kind of spontaneous energy we had
this process where we would take each
shot and act it out ourselves and when
you can like act little moments out
yourself there's sort of like a really
immediate nature to to that you take
that video reference and when you brief
the animator on the floor before they
they film it so we we actually do have a
version of the whole film with pretty
much just me and mikey acting out every
character in it which is is sort of
insane but um probably
for many people probably more
entertaining than the finnish thing some
shots would be made up of
multiple multiple exposures we use a
program called dragon frame which uses
references we're able to use like
overlay images with the camera to make
sure
if we're shooting multiple plates that
you know this element is going to match
up with this element but with the
software that we've got you've got a
live playback of every frame that you've
taken so far so a big part of the
animation process is like watching back
what you filmed and kind of anticipating
the next position of the character that
depth you see is achieved by shooting
various planes and elements such as
snowflakes snow drifts and silhouettes
separately on green screen which would
then be composited later by a visual
effects team every element in the film
is something that's been filmed um
rather than like making cg backgrounds
or anything like that i think the most
we had was 60 plates a plate being like
a piece of character animation or an
element or
a lighting exposure and we were really
inspired by like the kind of russian
filmmakers like in the in the early
years of stop motion like yuri norstein
and his like a film of hedgehog in the
fog where you get this really like
incredible sense of of depth and
atmosphere if you if you saw how it was
done it would be done in quite a low
fire way really the team used a
stereoscopic technique of shooting two
frames at slightly different angles at
once in order to capture depth that
would be useful later in post
so although we weren't making a 3d film
what this gave us was the depth
information that we wouldn't usually
have with the stop motion you usually
just come away from a scene with a flat
image but by shooting it stereoscopic we
were able to then use that depth
information to embed all of our elements
and so we could have raindrops passing
behind blades of grass and trees
disappearing into the mist and
characters moving through it all without
the need of green screen or rotoscoping
i'm not a
terrible man there was the clean up of
the the neckline and the eyelids of
robin our main character there's of
course the the integration of all the
elements the snow and the mist and the
fire and the water we also
um had the rigs to remove so there was
the the scaffolding that upholds all
these characters as they're moving along
the kind of elemental build-up of things
like rain was like quite complex the
magic of stop-motion is is that it's all
this craft kind of condensed into these
frames that you're watching all together
and there's a kind of magic and a sort
of level of intensity to that that we we
just love